research innovation Erasmus and the
migration crisis looks set to be the
European priorities for 2017 in any case
it certainly appeared that way in the
budget proposed by the member states
this summer now it's time for the MEP s
who share the power to adopt EE use
annual budget to debate their priorities
European budget is special in that it
contains two types of budget line on the
one hand there are commitments or legal
promises to spend money on certain
projects either in the same year as the
commitment or later and on the other
hand there are payments money that the
EU actually expects to pay out in a
given year the Member States draft
budget contains a seven percent decrease
in payments and a 0.9 percent increase
in commitments compared to the 2016 EU
budget on the side of the payments the
bulk of the budget is aimed at
supporting smart and inclusive growth
the big beneficiaries would be research
and innovation the European fund for
strategic investments and erasmus+ in
addition to this 5.2 billion euros in
commitments would be allocated for the
effective management of migration flows
and addressing root causes of migration
and finally security in the EU should be
hands through nearly 750 million euros
in payments this Wednesday MEP s will
debate the 2017 draft budget to define
their position for the following day
when the console Parliament and
Commission meet in trialogue over the
question
I